hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong i'm jacqueline
alongside my life partner we have better
chemistry than oscar isaacs and jessica
chastain
how you doing mark
oh you were missed jacqueline is the
first thing i'll say because we had a
great chat me and my new best friend
chance the rapper who
apparently wants to come on the show
like once a month and i say
bring it on we talked about hot rod and
we just started at hot rod and we went
to like nine other movies and i know
jaclyn we have a different movie and
another great guest this week but can
you just give the kids out there who
miss you on our episode you're you're
like one sentence log line about how you
feel about hot rod the way i feel about
hot rod is first of all i love that bill
hader like made his entire character off
of one of his friends from oklahoma
when you are born in the south there are
personalities
and things that like occur to you and
like that idea of him being on acid and
having something sticking out of his
head that really happened to someone and
i love the story of bill talking about
that his friend saw the movie and he's
like you know that happened to me he's
like yeah idiot he based it on you and i
just love that idea
um i i did get to listen to clips of the
episode you guys had such a great time
i'm sorry that my duties
um in the awards circuit uh took me away
from that conversation but tell your
ride how was it you were you were
hobnobbing with the fancy folk of the
earth i mean i was it's really funny it
was not a super spreader event i'm still
negative on kovit thank you very much
but uh it was fun it was really great
and i love seeing good movies uh
king richard you guys need to check that
one out also check out uh
the power of the dog which is the jane
campion so i gave you a nice popcorn
movie and a little auteur movie that me
and my friends will like huddle beside
and like pledge our love to but both of
those are gonna be part of the season
and maybe we can get those filmmakers on
the podcast
listening i hope you're listening mr
will smith mrs jane campion benedict
cumberbatch if y'all are out there we
want to have you on
bring it on but we're going to bring it
to a little bit more when we say popcorn
fair today um but we are going to also
take it out to the sea the movie this
week is
aquaman yes this is jason momoa living
his superhero fantasy dreams the score
is 65 fresh on the tomato meter but it
has a 74 audience score the reason why
we're talking about it this week well
you don't need much reason then jason
momoa is without a shirt for most of it
but the main reason why we're covering
it this weekend is director james wan
who directed aquaman has a new horror
film out malignant and we could not talk
about this film without bringing back
one of our certified fresh guests mr j
washington from blurred in the hood jay
i gotta ask you sir is rotten tomatoes
wrong about aquaman i would like to say
on behalf of everyone who'd like to
watch jason momoa just have every fun
you could have in a movie
yes ryan tomatoes wrong you get almost
two and a half hours and jason momoa
just like i get to wear my hair down and
act like a punk rocker in the water this
like it's you know it's one of those
movies that is just it's super fun and
people will expect it too much out of a
movie about a dude who talks to fish
like let's just be real it's a movie
about a dude who talks to fish and a
fish underwater kingdom why were y'all
expecting some cinematic masterpiece
which it is for what it is like it's
beautifully done like you get to see
what under the sea look like without
sebastian
under the sea without sebastian which
for me is not as great but
i'm still gonna say that you're probably
right on that one um
we're gonna get on to this one because i
think you're right i think people may be
trying to take this one too seriously
but let's be honest this is the dc eu
and up to this point they were kind of
known for that but mark why don't you
set the stage for us tell us
what exactly happened in our little
underwater adventure with mr jason momoa
as arthur curry an aquaman
well the guy that talks to fish that we
all made fun of in high school he's the
coolest superhero now back to you
jacqueline um no that and and if you're
watching this on one of our simulcasts
where you get the video too i am only
setting up this lighting for my hotel
room in vegas because it looks like i'm
actually underwater right now so i am
going with the theme of aquaman in this
particular iteration you do have this
badass hulk of a beautiful man jace
mamoa playing aquaman we get his
backstory where he is gonna be the
rightful heir to the throne of atlantis
which
we know from our reading is underwater
completely underwater but king orm
seizes that throne he's played by
patrick wilson and the abs did we all
see the picture whoo so he is now sort
of the baddie in this and he has an idea
he wants to unite everybody underwater
and rule all of them and then he wants
to take that army to the surface and rid
the earth of humanity why because we're
awful people and we pollute the ocean
and if you live in atlantis which is
again underwater you probably don't like
us too much but jason moe was aquaman
says well that's just not right and so
he's gonna step up and we have this big
battle between him and his half-brother
who's gonna win who's gonna carry on
well one of them's in the justice league
so you can probably do the math for
yourself ah
good good on you sir also we do have to
mention
um that he is a half breed between
nicole kidman and one of the voices from
moana i just had to put that out there
because like that is like one of the
prettiest half-breed babies
and the guys are fat yeah
both fat and boba fett both he was a
pretty happy breed baby since he was a
kid by the way they showed him as a kid
as a teenager i was like you were just
beautiful all your life like
beautiful chocolate superhero i live for
it okay so
let's go ahead um and say hi as she's
already you know jumped the gun as she's
known to do with miss perducy lucy
dancing in the back there
okay this is what i'm great this is okay
i didn't finish the movie last night
because i started it at 11 didn't
realize it was three hours long okay
um all i'm going to say about it
is that if they had cast lisa bonet
jason mamoe's wife in real life as mira
there would have been more chemistry
okay oh yeah i did not find
the the chemistry um that's all i'm
gonna say i think this jason momoa just
strikes you as a dude where it's like
he can have that brother-sister vibe
with you know like some ivory skinned
woman but you really know he needs like
a little bit of soul for him to get
going like i'm sorry like there's just
something about the dude where it's like
no i need a girl that wakes up with a
bonnet he looks
sorry
i'm sorry i need some cocoa butter to
get my juices going sorry
butter right there all right
yeah we're going there okay so jay
rotten tomatoes is wrong because you
feel like this is a good time but just
real quick give us you know anything
that you didn't mention up at the top as
to why it's wrong and maybe where you
think you should be
we don't give ya abdulmatin a second
enough credit you know you don't see a
super lot of him in the movie but every
time he's in there he gives you a
performance level that's like yo i'm
gonna take this villain to a whole
nother level of what you're gonna see
with the weirdest helmet eventually
because you know black mantas helmet is
weird but you you forego all of that
because of how yaya is in this movie no
i agree i definitely agree uh mark what
about you where are you feeling with it
is mar is rotten tomatoes wrong right
you know in there
i think rotten tomatoes is pretty
accurate with the 65 i could totally see
this getting up to where the audience
score is so i could probably have
aquaman around the 70s it's a very fun
movie and i just enjoyed the sheer bulk
of the cast like how many people are in
this because you have all these
different actors and actresses that
you've seen for decades popping up in
this what should be a ridiculous movie i
think the the achievement in aquaman is
that like i said in the synopsis aquaman
was a punchline before this movie came
out and it's like as soon as they
announced jason momoa's aquaman we all
took a step back we're like oh wait they
might be doing something really right
here and i think that that casting paid
off so i don't think that all of the
chemistry was necessarily on point to
lucy's um you know quick quick take but
i think that aquaman does enough right
to be a fresh movie so i'll keep it
where it is
agreed the one thing i will say i'm i've
been a bit hard on dcu movies i know
y'all have been listening i know you
know but the one thing i will say they
always get very very right is the
casting from will smith is deadshot to
harley quinn with margot robbie to
uh gal gadot as wonder woman to now um
jason momoa is arthur curry even when
they take risk or when they play it safe
they always i think find the perfect
person for these roles i just wish they
gave them sometimes better things to do
um but i'd say rotten tomatoes is
exactly right this score to me feels
exactly right i could see it a little
bit lower especially after the second
time yeah get indignant jay is fine
you're gonna have to talk you're a black
man on the internet surprise
that you decided to get indignant
by stuff that i had to say but listen no
it's it's it's right but i will say this
for as dumb as this movie is and this
movie is dumb this movie failed out of
second grade it's just dumb it's not a
smart movie i'm sorry
it is not it's dumb it's a dumb movie it
you know nothing against it it doesn't
mean it's a bad person but it needed
some help to make me feel like there was
anything going on worth watching but
dude jason momoa is having such a good
time he's having such a good time he's
having a good time jason wan uh sorry um
james wan is having a good time i think
everyone is having a good time in the
movie except for amber heard's wig but
everybody else is having a good time and
for that i'm with it
willem dafoe's harris willow defoes
harris having a good time he's even
having a good time even him with his
like you know i'm gonna be the shady
advisor like he's having a good time and
he played elias
having a great time dolph lundgren's
having a good time like everybody
committed to the absurdity and that is a
hard thing to do because you could
always tell that person who's just like
i know this is gonna be stupid
like i know this is gonna be stupid i'm
just here to get my check and so i don't
get fined like you can always tell when
there's that person there um but it was
no none of the people involved in this
everyone's having a good time and i
think that's why critics kind of gave it
a pass but
don't take my word for it
we have our review creation manager mr
tim ryan who's gonna break down for us
what the critics and fans were saying
about aquaman just three short years ago
when it hit theaters in a little segment
we like to call two minutes with tim
twoman
what's the best tone for a superhero
movie should it be exuberant and rousing
should it be dark and gritty or should
it be ludicrous and over the top aquaman
embraced the third approach and critics
were by and large receptive to its
fantastical visuals and its goofy charm
and though this isn't scientific by any
means i'm gonna go ahead and say that
the word goofy has never been used more
frequently by movie critics than in
their reviews of aquaman that being said
a number of reviews thought it was way
too long and way too busy and not all of
them thought goofy was a positive thing
it's fresh at 65 with 408 reviews and it
has a 74 audience score so what did the
critics have to say in a fresh review
richard roper of the chicago sun times
wrote the saving grace of director james
wan's great-looking and reasonably
entertaining but also meandering and
sometimes truly ridiculous aquaman is
that everyone from the screenwriters
through the talented cast seems to get
the sheer waterlogged lunacy however in
a rotten review jay coyle of the
associated press wrote the bright spots
mamoa that octopus can be difficult to
really relish amid the oceans of
exposition and a typically pulverizing
over-elaborate screenplay the rotten
tomatoes criticised consensus reads
aquaman swims with its entertainingly
ludicrous ride offering up cgi superhero
spectacle that delivers energetic action
with an emphasis on good old-fashioned
fun so that's aquaman jacqueline and
mark i'm sure that the discussion of
this movie will keep you
octopied for a while
back to you folks all right so as i said
silly what did he say goofy i think
goofy was the word he said right yeah
everything about this was like
pretty goofy but i don't know man i
remember i took me a while to watch this
one i watched it at home and i think i
just like one day used my fandango like
account and i was like all right i'm
gonna watch aquaman and i was surprised
i was digging it i liked it i had fun
with it uh but i don't know we're gonna
find out what you guys think about it in
our section called movie talk
[Music]
before we get into the scenes uh
jay let's talk about jason momoa we've
already had a little bit of love fest on
him but what do you think about him as
aquaman it's perfect because it changes
what if you read the aquaman comics if
you saw the super friends cartoons where
arthur curry was a blonde hair blue eyed
dude you're just like this is the lamest
superhero ever
and jason momoa the first time we see
him in the movie is when he bust in on
the submarine he goes permission to come
aboard with a little cute turnaround and
everything like that so like you have so
much fun with him also let's not forget
we get to watch him go from fun and
silly to a horror movie in the middle of
the movie when they get to the trench it
all of a sudden becomes a dark horror
movie and all the fun goes out the
window and you're just like this shifted
gears real quick
and he stayed with it though he flowed
with the transition like he could have
stayed goofy and stupid during the dark
part but he didn't so that's why i keep
saying tomatoes is wrong and i'm gonna
keep standing
[Laughter]
what about you mark i think like both of
us feel the same way about about him as
aquaman but i think it's better when you
gush over jason momoa i just feel like
this guy he's just cool he is just a
cool guy from back when it was drogo and
game of thrones so we're all like man
that dude is just a badass he's the guy
that men want to be and women want to be
with and so if you have him as aquaman
it instantly turns that perception that
i've had my entire life about that
character i can go all the way back to
the great mid 90s mtv sketch show the
state the state had a justice league bit
where it was superman and batman they're
assembling everybody and they keep
making fun of aquaman
they're talking about okay you need to
go stop the rocket you need to go do
this that aquaman you go talk to some
fish and they all start giggling and so
to go from that to the mid 2000s when we
had
no none other than entourage making fun
of aquaman that james cameron's gonna be
directing this and it's gonna get to be
this huge hundred million dollar opening
weekend property to the fact that it
actually did that this movie opened
around christmas and it actually hit the
100 million dollar market's opening
weekend so it was like entourage was
prognosticating for all of us something
that we could not imagine back when that
show was at its peak that you would have
aquaman and the and i i think that dc
did it right and i stand by this jay the
dc eu had to give us batman v superman
with a little bit of a tease of aquaman
and then justice league with aquaman
fighting amongst other superheroes
because i don't think that we alone
would have rushed into an aquaman
standalone movie before we got to see
what a badass he was fighting alongside
other superheroes that we were more
familiar with i see i'm the opposite i'm
like we had to wash that taste out of
our mouth before we committed
you and me in justice league jacqueline
oh my gosh look he looked very good with
like i do so one thing i will say they
incorporated jason momoa so much into
this character and i felt like james wan
was like the perfect director for this i
think you would have been correct if
maybe we didn't have james wan behind
the camera because i feel like they
could have really sort of i mean just
plain just whitewashed that character in
a lot of ways and they made a really
smart choice making it a polynesian
pacific islander like that part of the
character really made it more believable
because like literally it's the weirdest
thing in the world to be like so this
like very aryan looking dude was born
underwater like that whole like visual
of aquaman doesn't really mesh when you
think about the realities of how much
it's like you know he's island he's fish
and like just nature it's it's an
indigenous story in so many ways that it
makes sense to have that kind of person
uh portray that so i really love what
they did with that one and and again
just jason moe having like the biggest
amount of fun with it and look
nicole kidman
another one just showing up having a
good time like i don't know how james
juan convinced nicole kidman to like
give up working with meryl streep to
come and like play around with fishes
but thank the lord that she did because
that was so good it opened his seat to
open this seat you get to finally be an
action star nicole kidman we get to
watch you twirling around a try
whooping ass and being a bad like you
don't just become because the first day
make it like oh this is the damsel in
distress atlanta washes ashore and here
comes tom curry then all of a sudden she
wake up she's about to kill him like get
away she treats him like lelo treated
bruce willis in the fifth element but
then turn around when the guards from
atlantis come in she whoops all of them
so it's like you got to tell nicole
kidman you get to do something different
now yeah and that scene is it's so
important to have an actor of that
caliber in a movie like this i would
like a nicole kimmen in this to anthony
hopkins being odin and thor because it's
like thor is also sort of just a
ridiculous concept but if you have
somebody who is that revered with their
craft we all as an audience we know it's
nicole kidman even if we're pretending
it's not and we just buy into it a
little bit more and that opening scene
really locked me into the movie where
you're like oh no they're taking this
seriously and so now i guess i have to
as well
it's funny that you mentioned thor um
mark because okay this is gonna be one
of those i'm gonna pick up the name as
soon as i drop it but it's important to
the story so i was at telluride and one
of the movies there is belfast which was
directed by sir kenneth brenna yeah
and before kenneth branagh did thor he
was known for like shakespearean
adaptations and i remember when he was
announced as the director everyone was
like this dude did much do about nothing
what is he gonna know about like
superheroes and such and i actually got
to talk to him about that and he said
you know he's like thor was the first
comic i picked up when i was a little
kid and it is shakespeare he's like the
colors in that comic book are literally
what made me passionate about visual
sort of storytelling he's like because
when you look at a jack kirby comic they
lived for colors i mean like if you're
watching us right now on one of the
platforms you see all of jay's covers in
the background that's what what attracts
kids to comics very early on is that
colorfulness to it and the thing with
aquaman is the same thing that was thor
the reason why thor works is it's really
a shakespearean tale of woe and a
prodigal son they just happen to have
capes and superpowers
aquaman is indiana jones adventure it's
a it's a let's go find the artifact
treasure hunt adventure they just happen
to swim underwater and talk to fish but
the point of it is is like the parts of
the movie i felt that worked the best is
when they're on the hunt for the trident
and when they're trying to find the lost
you know mother and all of that i'm so
i'm so right there with you my favorite
scene in in aquaman i think is
so we get this great chase because we
realize we got to go find this this
legendary trident right and that's going
to be the thing that sort of balances
out the underwater kingdom and allows
aquaman to rule so we got to find the
trident we got to do it sooner rather
than later so we go to the sahara desert
to get the coordinates and then that
ends up giving us some sort of like
holographic thing where it it transports
us to sicily and there's an action
sequence in sicily that involves running
around and on top of roofs where it is
just such a cool looking
that is the reason why you pay james won
whatever he wants to do a movie like
this because the way that he sets that
action sequence up where you get a lot
of close quarters combat you also get
these sprawling chases that is like it
did remind me of indiana jones in the
last crusade where we get that we're
we're on boats for part of it and we're
chasing around looking for the holy
grail in this case we're looking for a
trident and it just like i was shoving
so much popcorn in my face during that
scene i'll show you the same mercy you
[Music]
the part where you see the the the
atlantean guard running through
everything it reminds you of that scene
in predator 2. remember when the
predator was running new things like you
the way you're shot and it's like
because you don't focus on you don't
focus on amber heard running off the
roofs you focus on him running through
buildings like he's stopping and going
stopping and going but you've been to
the sahara park mark and you forgot one
important key element that a lot of
people heard and was like am i hearing
this correctly and that was pit bulls
bastardization of toto from africa now
have anybody's name you're going to say
any reason why rotten tomatoes was right
about the score is because of that part
right there that is the one thing that
dropped every i was like is this really
happening like is people really doing
totals africa like while they jump out
of a plane i was so mad about that
like i was mad for
my 80s nostalgia because by the way if
you don't know toad of by africa is
literally the perfect song you can play
that in the middle of any environment
whether it be like the backwoods of
mississippi to like downtown detroit and
everyone will be like
you know what i mean and for people to
mess with that that's like
ah sacrilegious sacrilegious
i totally forgot that that was pit bull
i love that they put that song in that
scene but i forgot it was pit bull i
guess i just went right from toto to
weezer's cover of it which was pretty
good so i mean
it's at africa it's a one-of-a-kind
karaoke put it on your next karaoke
event kids you're not going to be
disappointed
i think for me um
it does go back to james wong because
like look um he came from like this
horror genre and the one thing about the
film which is interesting is the big
animal
octopus underwater creature part of it
that is him having his monster fantasy
and all of the scenes where they are
fighting sort of the demons from beneath
the deep are are definitely the ones
that i'm about like when when jason
comes into atlantis and sort of sees all
of the creatures that would have killed
him under any other circumstance and and
just seeing that sort of like because if
you've ever seen like underwater um deep
sea documentaries where they like go
down low with the like blue lights and
they look at these creatures that people
haven't seen before they're all
terrifying they all look like stuff that
you wouldn't want to be anywhere near if
you had anything for it and i really
appreciate how james embraced that
and more importantly like like i would
say leaned into it and also they were
clever
in most of the ways that they portrayed
being underwater without it feeling like
uncanny valley yes the way that and and
the way that they communicate with each
other underwater it's like well wait is
it going to be like when my brother and
i were kids and we go underwater and try
to figure out what the other person's
saying no we get these nice little air
bubble pockets yeah i think that was
just such a quick and clever way to
you know really bridge a massive gap
otherwise but
my problem with the movie is that
there's so much exposition that i didn't
think that we necessarily
needed you know and and maybe that's
getting to your point jacqueline about
how we get into the family dynamic the
shakespearean tragedy of this and
there's just a lot there and i think
that they they bit off a lot and i don't
think that we'd chewed at all yeah but
you gotta have it but you gotta kind of
have this
this this exposition because this is the
first time we're
really seeing atlantis for those who are
listening on the podcast
this is the first time we're really
seeing it so they're like okay we're
gonna make you realize this kingdom
isn't just kelp and seaweed and a few
things here and there there are all
these bright colors like they say we see
in these documentaries of deep sea
diving
this luminescence but also it's
technologically advanced it's so it's so
advanced you're like wait what there is
electricity underwater and everything
ain't there but it's so advanced and
then they even tell you the back story
of how they were already a
technologically advanced you know
society so i think the exposition is
needed because it makes you take
atlantis more serious now instead of
just looking at it this is just an
underwater thing it's a bunch of fish
what are you telling me
i did enjoy the i did enjoy getting to
know atlantis i will say that i thought
that that was that that was really cool
and really necessary i just found like
every relationship it felt like we had
to have this whole backstory for and i
just didn't need all of that
yeah the atlanta stuff is pretty sweet
yeah and i one thing i do remember is i
remember watching like this feature out
with james one where he talked about
atlantis and just how much detail and
how much time they spent on all of the
the subtleness of you know like the way
their armor looked like fish skills and
like all of that those little details
and they're all great but i will say i'm
a sucker for a good montage and willem
dafoe training
uh young young arthur curry like that
one i was like okay this this this
definitely hits me exactly where i want
to be and just like you know the the
reluctant slightly angry angry tutor
who's just like get it together kid like
i love that i live for that it's not
fair
this thing is so big and awkward why
can't i use a sword that's your mother's
trident
a traditional weapon of royalty you'll
never be a king until you've mastered it
why should you never come to see me huh
i told you when you're ready stop lying
to me
i've done everything you ever asked and
every time i pass a test you make up
another one that one kicks really hard
for me what about you jay what do you
have to pick when am i gonna learn how
to master the triton
like he was he was so arthur was so
disheartened because he was like
where's my mama like it was like you
felt the emotion because he's training
and also asking about his mother it
feels like his mother's abandoned him
and volco can't really tell him but you
were about to ask me another question
yeah no no i was just to say which one
is for you because like that to me i
think
for all of the details all of the
opulence all of the underwater like
that's the one that hits me but what
about you what's your favorite for me
it's a combination of finding of
understanding the different kingdoms of
atlantis especially when we go see the
fisherman's kingdom with jemon hansu who
is in every movie somehow some way yeah
jamal hassan will find a way to he plays
a fisherman's king but you see how again
the detail and how much beauty there is
and then you get to see the brine
kingdom you see uh you don't really go
fully into dolph london lundgren's
kingdom but you see about him you see
the different kingdoms of atlantis again
those were one of the best things about
it for me because it's like oh
there are more kingdoms under their
seven kingdoms seven seas all these
different things we hear and for me that
was one of the best things and don't get
me wrong i'm sure that's probably ripped
right from the atlantis legend and
whatever but i'm not gonna lie when they
started showing the other nations i was
like james juan cribbed this a little
bit from wakanda oh that's a little bit
do you remember what they did
when they did the trailers when they put
the trailer side by side everybody was
like oh um
i'm not saying he robbed it i'm just
saying
he may have been a little bit like i
like that we'll borrow aspects it's
inspiration yeah inspiration
uh speaking of let's talk about what
inspired some cringe because listen
we've had a bit of a love fest thus far
but let's keep it real some of this
dialogue felt like a dead fish
and there were a lot of cringy moments
oh that's good that's that's almost like
gene shallow territory
she earned that one yeah it was but
listen it's the facts
it's the facts now i personally will
okay so let me explain something to you
guys so whenever they're on movies
um they literally give out an oscar at
the end of the year for like hair and
makeup because it takes time
and effort and in a movie like this
where literally you're going to have an
actress who's going to have to look like
she's given the wet look
all the time there's probably a lot of
discussions about how you make that look
good on camera and
i don't know if they should have had
they should have had more discussions
because
amber heard's wig first of all
cysts from like the neck down in that
like wetsuit that was like molded i see
why you got the part girl like you look
good co-signed hair up
what happened
first of all she does not look good with
red hair
it's just like it's just the whole look
to just not work oh it did not work and
they had the chemistry have an eye for
for good or bad wigs like usually when
i'm in a movie i'm such a [ __ ] that i
just forget that there's hair and makeup
at all what's it like is that one of the
worst wig situations for you jaclyn as a
as a moviegoer oh no that's still shmar
more in dire the mad blood oh my jesus
he has these cornrows that are like
awful and for more maybe like seen by
larger portions of our audience i don't
know how many of y'all have seen entire
fairy movies but um
malik pfeiffer an eight mile
where he has that
yeah
excuse me makai pfeiffer in eight miles
fake dreadlocks is another one the girl
that played um
the girl that played star
what's her name starfire in the dc
girl
[Music]
but there's so many of them samuel
jackson has sported a few struggle hair
pieces in his day formula 51 as elmo
mcelroy those brains
i love calling them struggle wigs i
think that's they are struggling though
because they are like
but then you also have the fact that
like she's swimming around and it's like
and you're underwater for a lot of the
movie and you want that flowing hair
because that was the first time that we
saw aquaman it was in batman v superman
and it just emerges from the ship and
you just see it looks like a pantene
commercial yeah you just have this
flowing
locks and then he disappears you're like
what the hell was that show me more of
the hair it's like you get you get all
of the underwater look but you also get
a little bit of an 80s metal band vibe
with a lot of the atlanteans with a lot
of the underwater action here and so i
am all for flowing locks bad wig good
wig i don't care give me if you are an
underwater creature or half human or
whatever grow your hair out didn't they
have to did they have to like color
correct cause
it's only made red for amber hurts wig
after editing and everything because
it's not that red when they actually
shot it it's bright it's bright red
right yeah so how many of those little
ping-pong balls and dots were on her
hair on set whatever like we need to
make these exact strands get this darker
red like it's just it is bad it is just
like it's supposed to look wet but it
looked dry all the time it's like what
is like
another bad struggle wig um folks will
remember this one the kid from twilight
um the wolf one taylor lautner
that wig is a struggle wig
you remember this
yeah i remember this week it's not
difficult i i'm passionate about this as
well it's because the wheel of time is
about to come out
and i'm reading the books i'm obsessed
and rosamond's pike
roseman pike's hairpiece
there are women that wear wigs every day
they have the fake scalp it looks
incredible they know how to do the like
the this part
what's this called
they look real it looks real yeah how
does um how does warner brothers not
invest
or any of these big budget places
investigating
all that scalp all the air reverse shows
because all the stephen the male wigs
they put on words terrible i'll tell you
this is why this is why the people who
do those wigs very well and like
literally are like the highest thing
there's like 10 of them and they're all
working with black actresses as their
permanent hair stylist so like lupita
nyong'o's hair stylist that like did her
hair for like half of the stuff for
black panther and like all those people
they're in such high demand and they're
usually paired with black actors and
actresses because if you go on set and
you're getting ready to go for a
three-month movie like issa rae the
woman who does her hair she's like a
really famous um hair stylist she
literally is just like when issa goes on
set yeah i'm you have to use my hair
stylish for the whole shoot this morning
so they're gone a hundred and sixty
million dollars it's not that they can't
afford it they just cannot get them
because these people have loyalty mark
mm-hmm 160 million was the cgi mark
let's just let's just be real look at
all the all the fishes the different
efficiencies well okay that that's
that's what i'm gonna sort of stand up
for and i'm gonna represent all of those
poor sea creatures that we lost because
mark hoffmeier our expert researcher put
a great note in there he made a random
observation that is going to be my
cringe moment here is that there's a lot
of dead whales at the end at the end of
the movie and and hof i agree with
hoffman where he's like why would you
send endangered species if you care
about the
underwater creatures why are you sending
endangered species to come fight when
you already have all of these huge
monsters that are gonna basically turn
the tide for you why are you throwing
willy in there why are you throwing
flipper in there why are you even
throwing bruce the shark into a battle
like this where you're basically just a
sacrificial pawn i mean come on aquaman
if you care about underwater creatures
you talk to these fish on a daily basis
be better
thank you thank you mark hoffmeyer for
for eliminating that
yeah but that epic battle is pretty
awesome though i will say that i know
what my cringe moment is what julie
andrews is the caravan
what oh yeah
she's the giant monster yeah mary
poppins is the giant monster that tells
arthur if king atlan doesn't find you
worthy i haven't eaten an eons yeah i'm
famished
what
also before people fight me black
panther actually came out the same year
is it is it what year the black panther
come out was it 2018 2018.
february of 2018 and then this was like
christmas this was like christmas so i'm
not saying that james juan cribbed
the story
but
not saying that he didn't either it's
the same story in reverse i'm just
saying i'm just saying aquaman is
killmonger in the situation if you look
at it arthur curry is killmonger yeah
and you also have that like that that
king that uh nerius that's played by
dolph lundgren here who
is sort of gets fooled into an into an
alliance with the bad guy
orm but you also never really trust
dolph lundgren's intentions and part of
that is because we're so conditioned to
know him as drago because this was the
year that
this was the resurgence this season was
the resurgence of dolph lundgren because
he was also back as drago in oh where he
had florian monteneux as his son which i
just
my love for bill hader is it transcends
space and time i will forever pledge for
him i love him so much but if you just
want to talk about who was ripped off
the pages of the romance novels that i
have read way too many of that is
florian monteneux that dude looks like
he can break women in the best of ways
and i'm sorry
watching him on screen
i like watching him on screen ladies if
you want to check out shanghai let me
tell you he comes in also check out his
instagram page you will not be
disappointed okay enough objectifying of
uh stars of different movies hey i've
been i've been objectifying momoa since
we started the show i mean seriously
though this is definitely a beefcake
parade in all of the best ways also
though too like what's great about jason
momoa is for as much as he is like um
a sex symbol for women or whatever he's
also just like a good dude and we'll
talk about maybe a little bit like
behind the scenes but like any dude who
who like gives his wife her very first
car he like took his wife's first car
loose bonnet and he restored it it was a
19 i think 69 mustang and he literally
like did it up to where it was beautiful
again like you can just tell that dude
loves um on loud like he just loves on
loud and he's just like it seems like a
good dude who just wants to be a good
family man and have fun when he's making
movies okay so yeah that that's all
that's all nice and cute if i had the
body of jace mamoa i'd be restoring cars
outside all day too by myself and
nothing but some jeans and timberlands
97 degrees outside i'm just i was
just outside sweating yeah and if i was
lisa bonnet i'd be out there wiping the
hood let's be honest if i look like she
may i would be doing this
i mean this is a woman that literally
got the love and affection of jason
momoa and lenny kravitz and had babies
with both
there's something special about homegirl
you talk about royal bloodlines that's
that's the family we're looking at and
they're and luckily for us they're above
water that they're actually on earth and
they're not underwater and so we don't
get to see them and objectify them as
much they're here and we get to enjoy
them each and every day and each and
every week in us weekly but i'm also
going to say this real quick yeah i
don't hate and maybe this is actually a
credit to the movie i don't hate where
orm is coming from he's the bad guy we
know that i don't hate where arm's
coming from because he's basically like
look i'm gonna unite i'm gonna rule i'm
being a dick that i want to be the
dictator but i also want to obliterate
everybody above the ocean because
they're ruining and they're polluting
earth yeah i don't necessarily hate that
and i'm not sure
that i was won over that aqua why
aquaman would care about us i know
there's some cool superheroes that he's
now friends with but i don't know that i
wouldn't just want to get rid of
humanity either i'm not sure about
getting rid of humanity but when they
did that trash jumping scene i'm like i
would like that to happen because i've
been to way too many dirty beaches and
like the idea of being like here you
drop this to the entire shore
not gonna lie i liked that moment that
was a that was a very good one it's one
of those things too it's sort of like
the samuel l jackson character in um
kingsman you know these these people
like even thanos to a certain respect
like all of these people who are trying
to do nefarious things for the greater
good
i don't agree
with your methods but i understand the
necessity because i think if anything
the past few months have told us left to
our own devices not everybody's going to
understand the assignment yeah and
there's seven billion people and so
there there's way too many to just for
orm in like his armies to just go above
ground and just be like okay you're bad
you're good you're bad just gonna wipe
the whole site queen and i will say to
all of our viewers who are watching us
out here this is the same straw that
i've been using all week in vegas i do
not i do my best to recycle plastic
straws because they're not good for the
ocean so
hey look at this with my with my
horrible
mcdonald's unsweet tea i have a metal
straw because that is what i do oh yeah
this is the thing with arm though he set
up his kingdom to go to war like my
man's hired black manta to attack him
to like yo all right cool here you go
bro he's like oh it's like it's like a
fake assassination yeah yeah like you
got all your gold pieces and you got
black man who's like hey bro i don't
need all this money just help just give
me dude like can you imagine how
obsessed you're like he killed my father
he killed my father that is his that is
his father is played by michael beach
too michael beach was my father and
somebody murdered him i would definitely
go on the parade come on ma'am this is a
wendy's
i would go on the parade i will kill you
i will kill you like vanessa williams
tried to kill him in soul food that is a
deep cut for people that didn't know we
need to get we're gonna we're gonna get
out of here on movie talk
we're gonna go
into behind the scenes before we talk
about any more randomness this is what's
great about having j on is we just go on
tangents but they're fun tangents uh
let's go ahead and transition over to
behind the scenes brian cue the music
[Music]
all right everyone we wouldn't be here
we wouldn't have had aquaman which would
again was doing a tall order because
wonder woman and what patty jenkins did
with that really sort of set literally a
high water mark both with audience
tomato meter and not box office but
definitely all those three things coming
together wonder woman was the year
before aquaman came out and it sort of
like set the stage and here comes james
and like i just wonder is it because
they trusted him more than other
directors cause cat patty jenkins talks
about how like wonder woman the first
one really wasn't one where she had the
control she would have liked but you can
just tell james juan
let him do what he wanted in this am i
wrong i don't know jay what do you feel
no he got he got the free again james
juan is a horror director which is why
you get a horror movie in the middle of
a bright beautiful comic book movie that
that's like that's how they let you know
you do what you want you you do what you
want we just like they didn't even give
him notes where this needs to connect
the only thing he had to do was have
have mirror say you fought steppenwolf
that's it
everything else is its own things yeah i
i love that that comic book movies are
are doing this with the directors they
choose now where they're allowing them
to bring
their genre history
to the material in the same way like if
you had a show if you had a game show
that you needed a host for and you hired
jay or me because we're comics we're
going to pepper in jokes like that
that's that's where we're coming from
and so in the same way that i think
people got really excited when scott
derrickson was doing doctor strange and
he's gonna bring some horror to that or
even now sam raimi doing the sequel to
that you have james wine and we said oh
this guy's good at doing horror stuff
what sort of like creatures are we gonna
get what sort of are we gonna get a jump
scare in aquaman and it's just he's got
such a good eye for stringing the viewer
along just just giving us enough
information that we can piece it
together but that's why i felt like all
the exposition felt like it weighed the
movie down is that i feel like he was
saddled with a lot of that yeah to do
because it's like it's like when ryan
coogler does black panther you let him
make his movie i would have liked and i
hope that with the sequel that they let
james juan make his movie a little bit
more with the lost kingdom or whatever
the hell that sequel is going to be
called yeah i mean i think it's
something that marvel went through that
i think we talked about it on one of our
recent episodes and things like iron man
3 where i talked about this you know
early days of marvel was known like like
not just in a rumor instance but in a
point-blanking period told
marvel is hard to work for because they
have this huge vision and they are not
going to let you do what you want and i
think um
it's interesting they've kind of backed
off on that and it's something that's
happened i think like the studio with
age but also even directors i recently
saw a quote from james uh cameron him
talking about how he's changed making
this avatar versus the first one like he
used to be the type of director that'd
be like man this is what we're doing
give me this line this way you know
whatever and he says he's eased up in
his age of like
trusting that he's working with people
who know what they're doing and i think
they're all slowly but surely becoming
like ron howard ron howard has always
been that kind of director where he
really is about the collaborative
process he never takes it as an offense
when someone asks a question in the
middle of a setup or anything like that
and i hope that was part of aquaman too
i mean look they're they're making it
right now
uh yaya who was just barely you know a
guy that people knew uh when this
happened and by the time this comes out
he will have done the watchmen candyman
and matrix
um it's just interesting to think about
where he's shifted in in his time and
look this one made money i do feel like
aquaman two if we get like one of those
good trailers one of those good good
trailers we're probably gonna be in a
different point with uh the global box
office and how it's been affected by the
pandemic i mean this thing has got some
very billion dollar aspirations and
potentials that could very much happen
as long as you don't change the formula
in a sense you can just up the ante just
don't change what worked
i think that because a lot of times
you'll have that happen when movies get
so successful where they go into the
sequel and somebody's like no we can do
this whole thing differently i like
deadpool 2. that's why it wasn't
received as well as it was as the first
one was there was something about the
first one but then the second one
granted yes you changed directors and
everything but you changed what worked
if james one sticks to what for a lack
of better words what he knows what works
with aquaman and just enhances on it
then yeah we're looking at another
billion dollar box office again all
things considered with the pandemic and
everything yeah it would have to be some
some good timing too just because
with with dc i think that the fact that
the dcu is so confused as to what it
wanted to be and we still don't really
know what any timeline looks like
because we don't know if we're getting a
if if henry cavill's ever coming back we
don't know about some of these
characters and so i think that james
juan getting to make another aquaman i
hope that they still keep it stand alone
because sometimes when i go see a comic
book movie i want to see the other
heroes sort of pop in like captain
america civil war sometimes i just want
to see a stand-alone adventure and i
hope we get that with aquaman and the
lost kingdom because i do think there's
so much potential there i'd be lying
though if i said i wasn't super excited
for malignant because it's james bond
returning to direct a horror movie
jacqueline have you seen it yet
no i haven't seen it yet but i'm i
haven't seen yet but i'm definitely
gonna check it out um i i it's so funny
basically until
just a little bit before me starting
this movie my anxiety and like fear of
being scared really kept me away from
the horror genre and i've come to
realize now that i don't hate the horror
genre i just don't like too much
gore so like if you can find a good
horror movie where i'm not like
literally like like worried that i'm
watching like almost like a surgery like
i have a aversion to the type of horror
stuff that makes me feel like i'm
watching one of those like um pbs
documentaries where they're doing the
surgery with the camera you know what i
mean i'm like i want to see that but i
don't want to see that in any movie and
it's just i think all the horror movies
i used to watch early on were that and
so i've i've learned to go back and look
at a lot of things that you know james
wan did things that he produced and
really come to enjoy him as a director
later on and so yeah i'm definitely
going to check this one out also too the
one thing i will say about the sequel of
aquaman is was true with the first one
this is a movie that i think really um
is close to jason momoa's heart in the
sense that he really identified with
that i didn't know this and it was from
the research uh he grew up in like uh
like basically like wisconsin area like
he grew up as like the one brown kid in
like
bridges of madison square county uh area
basically and he graduated very young he
was a late bloomer so he graduated super
skinny and brown in the sea of white
people and so he very much identified
with this whole aquaman story of like
just feeling very different and i think
embracing that aspect of the story
now that he is literally going to be
sitting on the throne of atlantis that's
not going to change any he's going to
feel still like an outsider and i think
leaning into that kind of stuff is
really interesting it's what make
guardians of the galaxy interesting it's
what makes a movie like black panther
interesting anytime you can really find
those universal things that a lot of
people have dealt with and build the
superhero craziness around it it's
always going to be really good speaking
of the mcu do you all know the i guess
this will be my trivia for today do you
know what role or what movie jason mamoa
auditioned for in the
mcu what role thor
he auditioned
he auditioned to play somebody in
guardians of the galaxy i don't know
if it was like starwood he also met with
the russo brothers they were trying to
find like a villainy sort of role for
him in the mcu and it just didn't work
out and i'm i am thankful it didn't
because i feel like that this guy is one
of a handful of people on earth who can
literally carry an entire franchise on
their shoulder so i don't want to see
him just pop in as like a cool like
frank grillo was awesome as crossbones
and i think that that's perfect for him
i think that jace mamoa just he is
he's just one of those rare folks that i
will go see a movie because he's on the
poster he was great in that stallone
movie in that that's
a question
uh mark mr ellis out of all the people
who play roles within the marvel
cinematic universe frank grillo
was the one you went to no no because
he's not like he's good
frank grillo though the crossbones one
is the one choo choo
i got love for frank grillo
when they said does anyone want to get
out of the elevator come on now it was
who's crossbones who's
he's the guy that is the reason why we
have the sokovia i'm joking i i mean
this is technically true that is that
that is true jacqueline
crossbones is the reason for the sekovia
accords
the best punisher movie we've ever
gotten is frank grillo and the purge
anarchy and i will not yes okay yeah
on this program okay i'll take you with
that one and you know what you know what
jay and jaclyn he's never needed a wig
as far as i know
oh man okay that's a great place to end
uh
our behind the scenes stock
we are going to rip open the mailbag in
a new
version we're gonna we're gonna do a
little bit different this time but let's
let's rip open the mailbag uh brian cue
the music
[Music]
okay so a little bit different i want
y'all to listen up because we've got an
audio clip from a member of the ketchup
crew
nick burrows
uh nick burrows sent us an audio clip so
let's take a listen hello producey lucy
it's nick burrows calling from
switzerland but i'm originally
australian if you can't tell this is not
a swiss accent love you guys love the
podcast i've been a listener since day
one i can't believe you guys have been
going for so long now but it's my weekly
entertainment as i go around and put
these things in
so a couple of things um because i got a
list uh first of all movie that you have
to do and i'm not even looking it up on
rotten tomatoes to see where we're at
but prometheus the prequel prequel of
all prequels
i love it and i love it love it love it
love it love it and i'm a big fan of
alien aliens marion 3 meh whatever but
whatever just weedy stuff fine um and
then you know before we can just pretend
that one didn't happen and whatever but
prometheus the setup even though it's
not an aliens movie um noomy replaced
like i mean come on
there's you know the the way it's taking
on robots and stuff like i really think
in advance the fx are good the story is
[ __ ] awesome
i don't know i'm pretty sure that it's
rotten as all hell and it's probably got
a better audience score which is
probably underrated so i'd really love
to hear your guys feedback on that one
second point
and maybe i'll just leave it as a second
point and i won't go into the rest of my
list is that i think your format is
wrong i think rotten tomatoes is wrong
is wrong in terms of its format and i
reckon you guys should have
audience people rather than other
critics on i appreciate the other
critics you have on and the other social
people you have on they're cool and
everything but i think you really need
some voice of the people
and the real people that aren't mixed up
in the world of how do we review this
and having that critical eye you just
need some balls to the wall people that
can come in and talk about not knowing
anything about who's who and what's what
and all that sort of stuff and give a
completely diverse opinion and i'm
putting my hand up for it have me on
your show for a prometheus special
all right take care guys thanks
nick
thank you nick if that was an audition
tape cast that man this is gonna be like
spielberg at the end of et audition you
got the part kid you got the part it's
also the beauty of having a jay
washington on because jay is a man of
the people jay walks amongst them each
and every day he can be highfalutin he
can put a critical eye on things but he
doesn't have to be he still represents
the voice of the public at large and i
will say nick good news for you
prometheus is fresh
73
percent what is wrong with you people
promising
terrible
i actually want to talk about this
because i
prometheus was my man of steel there are
certain movies that i had to watch four
or five times before i could stay awake
for them and prometheus is one of them
it took me four times watching that
movie to stay awake i am not as big of a
fan as jacqueline jacqueline you didn't
want to see the michael fassbender
michael fassbender love affair girl
i'm just i'm gonna say this did they
drag idris elba into that too
is it just elven now in idris l
elban to prim look i don't remember if
herself is in it or not but i here's
what i do remember about prometheus it's
it's a gorgeous looking movie i think
the mythology is very interesting i am
so tired of astronauts having sex in
outer space
they did drag they did drag idris elba
into that one it just elvis in that
movie this is before it's just elbow
ages but yes they did drag idris elba
into that movie
it was post-wire
pre-star trek if you're gonna if you're
gonna have sex astronauts wait until
after the mission okay don't do it
you gotta have a clear head you gotta
have your head going into the mission
you're not thinking straight you are
afterwards you are after sex have you
not thought straight after sex work
yeah um
the last time it happened so i gotta go
back to like college
let me
let me check the old diary all of the
women who have been in the string of
mark ellis since then are gonna like
rush rotten tomatoes is wrong they're
going to be emailing us rt is wrong and
rotten tomatoes um i hook up mark ellis
on the road in las vegas like in 2004 i
don't know why he's trying to pretend
that we didn't
oh my god
he had this one straw that he kept from
a starbucks drink and he was like it's
special this is from this is my 2004
straw this is my good luck vegas straw
wait are you serious are there worms in
that
like in prometheus
okay nick producey lucy looks like she's
on board with this idea i'm definitely
on board with this idea your audio clip
was absolutely amazing and in fact it's
like definitely made me be like if you
all want to send audio clips please do
because the audio really does liven it
up and i don't have to read things and
and make my dyslexia be strained even
more than it is also you did a show
didn't he sound like joel
he did so
uh
who produces his podcast with us and has
been
we've never seen joel and nick in the
same room at the same time i mean are
they the same person is that like joel
just disguising it joel's voice is a
little bit posher but he may be like you
know like getting it a little bit more
for the street just to just to disguise
it i'm putting that out there and if
nick comes on i kind of want joel to
come on too so we can just aussie aussie
aussie it up anyway
that's gonna be it for us today as
always mr j washington it is always a
pleasure to have you on to talk movies
with us it is literally a joy i can't
believe they pay us to do this job but
sir before you get out of here please
let us know they do pay us they do pay
us don't pretend like you don't get paid
either
it is a joy talking with you all and
finding out about the worst wigs in
hollywood
you know what other life lessons would i
rather have but always twitter instagram
at mr j washington m r j a you should
notice about washington blurred in the
hood every tuesday and thursday youtube
and twitch 6 pm pacific 9 pm eastern
myself and my co-host western a marshall
we talk about the world of pop culture
news sports entertainment politics and
all that more from a blurred perspective
and we are unapologetically black
youtube.com blurrs in the hood ble
ble-rds the letter n-t-h-e-h-o-o-d but
more importantly my stand-up special my
mini stand-up special educated insanity
drops tomorrow tomorrow on youtube
thanks to the funny media group so i
have all that up on my social medias so
please check that out and just bump it
up and send the love and laugh and all
that good stuff and just have a little
fun with me going wild for a while all
right you got a movie recommendation for
us because i know you'd be watching
things
oh yeah uh my movie recommendation would
be
killer clowns from outer space because
where else can you find clowns who kill
people and cotton candy and suck them up
like slurpees while the clowns look
devishly cute but demonically evil at
the
time one the little short one to like
good
same
little short little fat pudgy one that
runs around everybody's like oh look at
him and he'd just be murdering people i
mean all of them be murdering killer
class about space man you better watch
that movie bart yeah i i remember seeing
it when i was a kid i just never i don't
remember falling in love with any of the
clowns being like oh i want to get one
like i i'm going to keep them at an
arm's length okay i don't trust clown
folk
yeah i agree i agree there's a reason
why people are scared uh jay again thank
you so so much and i will say this um
for me personally um
this when this comes out the next day
i'll be getting ready to cover the emmys
and i just recently caught up with all
of ted lasso
and i am now completely up to date on
that show it is
unbelievably great i cannot believe
speaking of ted lasso jacqueline uh when
you were out of town i did get all of
the packages that were sent to your
house
i'm holding them hostage they're not in
vegas i did not bring them to vegas
they're in my apartment so you can call
one of our maybe one of our neighbors to
retrieve them but if i need to yeah for
all of our listeners i did faithfully
retrieve all of jaclyn's packages before
they got stolen so i'm not gonna lie to
you mark is my buddy and the reason why
is i actually got this package that
literally just screamed steal me and
because it said a very popular show that
i may have mentioned on the side of it i
was like this is not gonna make it to
when i get back so i asked mark to help
me out and he did because he's a friend
and he could be a friend of yours if you
want to email us at rt is wrong at
rotten tomatoes don't forget to like
follow subscribe tell your friends we've
had such great response to the podcast
lately and it is all because of y'all
and next week mark we're doing one
that's heavily requested i believe next
week is this correct people have been
begging for us to do this movie they
want justice they want this person this
star to get what they so richly have
deserved for decades now and that would
be encino man star brendan fraser we're
not doing encino man we're actually
doing the mummy starring brendan frazier
we have a lot of fans that have hit us
up on social media saying you've got to
talk about any brennan fraser movie but
particularly the mummy so we're going to
give some of them a shout out on that
show and our good buddy eric striffler
from pretty much it is going to be
gushing about the mummy i hear he is a
big fit like
he owns mummy merch i hear that's how
big of a fan he is yeah i'm gonna be a
[ __ ] right about that i think you're
right about that all right thank you all
we will see you all next time on rotten
tomatoes is wrong on behalf of ducey
lucy mr j washington my co-partner mark
ellis and brian perez behind the audio
we want to thank you guys and we'll see
y'all next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you